at this altitude this episode is brought
to you by athletic greens I've used
athletic greens for many many years and
I'm asked all the time if you could use
only one supplement what would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is my all in one nutritional
insurance at least that's how I think
about it it is much more than greens
it's a complete whole food supplement
with 75 or so ingredients packed into
one tablespoon per day so when I travel
for instance of course I would like to
follow all of my regimens all of my
pills all of my supplements all of my
food to the tea but sometimes
circumstances intervene and you're too
busy or things are too hectic this helps
me to mitigate the likelihood of getting
sick and to perform optimally so if I go
to say South America for an AcroYoga
intensive which I did in Colombia at one
point I was running around like a
chicken with its head cut off and I took
this every morning and it is extremely
extremely helpful and I usually travel
with travel packets among other things
so you should try it out is the short
version of this as listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show you can receive $100 worth
of travel packs for free when you order
that's 20 free additional individual
travel pouches when you order simply go
to athletic greens dot-com forward slash
Tim to check it out so take a look at
lytic greens.com forward slash Tim
this podcast is brought to you by me
undies does this year's Valentine's Day
have you stumped
are you a big dumb animal well skip the
cliches and give a gift that looks great
feels amazing and makes everybody happy
me undies me and ease knows that you're
special someone deserves a special
fabric which is why their underwears
made exclusively out of micro Modell a
fabric three times softer than cotton I
can feel it on my loins right this very
moment because I've spent the last six
months at least wearing underwear from
these guys 24/7 and they are the most
comfortable and colorful underwear you
can add your own character to your own
underwear if you don't love your first
pair of munities they say they will hook
you up with a free pair a new pair or a
refund but are you really an [ __ ] who
returns used underwear if you are please
stop listening to my podcast that's
disgusting
they offer free shipping in for a
limited time listeners of this podcast
get 20% off of their first order just go
to Mia undies dot-com forward slash Tim
that's me undies dot-com forward slash
Tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Paris
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world class performers of
all types to tease out the habits
routines beliefs sometimes very strong
beliefs that they have or philosophies
that you can apply in your everyday life
and take for a test-drive this episode
is a treat it was a lot of fun to do my
guest is Kara Swisher at Kara Swisher on
Twitter ka ra s WI SH er she's been
called quote Silicon Valley's most
feared and well-liked journalist and
quote by New York magazine specifically
Benjamin Wallace that is such a good
headline and it's an even better piece
so I suggest you check that out as well
here's just one example of why she is
feared and respected you can graph the
impact on Yahoo's stock price of various
posts by Kara that's just the tip of the
iceberg she attended Georgetown School
of Foreign Service prior to changing
course journalism and as it turns out
many of the skills that would make a
good spy let's say are the same that
make a good journalist developing
sources asking good questions scenario
planning and much more she forged
reputation at the Washington Post in The
Wall Street Journal and now she spends
the majority of her time as executive
director of recode and the host of the
recode decode podcast over the last 11
years and alongside Walt Mossberg she's
also produced D all things digital a
major high-tech conference with
interviewees such as Bill Gates Steve
Jobs and many other leading players in
the tech and media industries there's
almost always I think it probably is
always a waiting list to attend this
event and in this podcast episode she
and I cover a lot of subjects enjoy
quite a few laughs and dig into details
you can readily apply and test yourself
topics include the art and craft of good
questions lessons learned in favorite
moments from interviewing Steve Jobs
some great war stories what separates
good from great journalists then we have
more war stories missed opportunities
and optimistic pessimism it's very
wide-ranging and I'll leave it at that
without further ado please enjoy my
conversation with Kara Swisher
kara welcome to the show thank you Tim I
am so excited to be here I am excited to
be here even more so and I will I would
be lying if I said I weren't just a
little nervous
Mison because you're so experienced and
so good at asking questions well you're
saying manipulating people yes I am and
fantastic at it so just accept that fact
just let's move on all right we're
moving on what separates in your mind a
good journalist from a great journalist
um you know it's interesting people ask
me it's all the time because I do tend
to be people a lot I tend to it's pretty
easy in lots of ways to do better than
other people and I think about a lot and
and a lot of people think there's some
special sauce or some magic or you have
a particular skill and I think there are
skills that you can develop but I
actually do think I just work harder
than people I just work I just work
harder and I try harder and I am more
persistent I guess that would be it what
do you do more of or less of if you were
to say compare your focus and the way
you work to people who are unable to do
what you do they're lazy I just really
don't know house putting two things it's
not just laziness it's laziness and lack
of observation and awareness then the
skills that reporters should have our
persistence ability to ask questions and
just an ability to analyze you know and
I mean like I talked about this a little
bit I went to the school Foreign Service
at Georgetown I was gonna be a spy and I
do a lot of scenario building whenever I
think about things or what I'm thinking
about companies or businesses and so
often when I'm thinking about what some
companies doing or what I want to cover
like for example Twitter and sale just
anything it could be any any errant
thing I go what would I do
what are those [ __ ] up to what could
they be up to and there's ten things
there's usually there's not more than 10
things they could be up to and I follow
every one as if it's the truth and then
I find the right one and it's really
it's really pretty easy
and I think reporters don't they're so
reactive something happens and then they
write it and they tend to type it down
and they never take a minute to analyze
it they never take a minute not to react
to imagine what people could be doing so
you can almost create your news if you
start to get smarter about it and most
reporters literally just react and type
and so that's what I find why did you
not become a spy I wish I did I was gay
at the time it was hard I'm pretty old
Tim I'm 54 and at the time and people
forget this and maybe it'll happen again
I don't think it will it was hard to be
gay it was you had to be furtive and
unhidden at the time I was somewhat
hidden not completely but enough there
was a price when you when you came out
and there were all kinds of issues
around being out and being in government
at the time and remember we had Don't
Ask Don't Tell for a while which was
insane before that a lot of punitive
things that would happen your own family
would be awful and so you know I
remember talking to someone at the time
and they were like well you obviously
couldn't be deployed to Saudi Arabia
because they hate gay they want to kill
people they want to kill the gay people
across the world and I was like mom I
don't speak Arabic so that wouldn't work
out for me you know what I mean that
kind of thing and so it was just a
constant like things I couldn't do
besides being a woman also so I think it
was that and I think I would've been a
good spy I would be like Carrie Mathison
without the bipolar I would that's the
kind of spy I would have wanted to be
what what drew you to that and following
that track in the first place I studied
at at college and then later at
journalism school at Columbia propaganda
I'm really interested in probably uses
of propaganda and the effectiveness of
propaganda and probably why I'm
attracted the internet because it has
such a huge it does its propaganda in a
lot of ways and so I would study
communist propaganda systems Nazi I was
very interested in how the Nazis managed
to yes how they know means admiration
but it was effective and so I was I was
really interested how they could take a
whole group of people and make them
demonize them the subtle forms of it all
the different things and so I was really
interested in that and and I was
interested in how people are fooled and
tricked and how easy it is to manipulate
people and so I was I wanted to not do
that and make things clear for people
I'm both offended by propaganda and
fascinated by it and so I wanted to say
you know and I'm doing on a lesser level
and I've started to write about Trump a
lot which i think is more meaningful to
me with companies
like so-and-so Yahoo tells you this well
let me just actually tell you what's
going on like it's not it precisely a
lie but it certainly isn't the truth and
I think Silicon Valley is one of the
places that tries to suspend disbelief
almost all the time and sometimes it's
great because you have to believe in
yourself and other times it's just pure
[ __ ]
more [ __ ] lately than anything else
a lot of [ __ ] out there yeah there
is so part of I would imagine discerning
the truth and building up these
scenarios and traveling down say10 paths
until you identify the the the proper
story the real story is sources right
how do you this this all makes so much
more sense to them thinking about the
spy context very have you think we've
landed in favorite how am I going to
cultivate my resources how do you
cultivate what are things yeah how do
you call them in terms of tricks they're
tricky you know they're conversations I
think I do them actually without a lot
of thinking about it but if I had to
think is I think I'm pretty charming
I think I'm interesting I think a lot of
reporters are transactional I'm not
transactional I don't like tell me this
give me this that kind of thing I
conduct relationships with my sources
over years and I think they appreciate
that because I sometimes give them
information I have a lot of infirmity
and so I don't trade information
particularly but I like I know things
and I have insights and I had someone
call me the other day who's been a very
good spirits very well-known person and
they asked about semantics oh no no you
don't wanna do that because of this they
didn't know and they're oh thank you and
I think this is the way you should do
that and I don't I'm not like giving
them free advice or anything like that
it just was I I develop relationships
the way you would talk to a person that
you anybody anybody that you have a
relationship with and so I think that
and I'm not ignorant that's the other
part is I know more than they do and
I'll never forget I was doing the book
on AOL with Steve Case and he was very
restrictive restricting information is a
trick that everybody uses I'm gonna
restrict the information and then you'll
be at my beck and call and at one point
during I had what I do is I into
hundreds of people I own everyone around
him so I get all the stories and at one
point he said something I oh no no
actually it happened like this and he's
like oh and then we did it again and I
was like no no actually I talked to this
person this is what happened he goes
I have no control over you anymore do I
and I go now that would happen weeks ago
no [ __ ] idea so I use that I use in
for lots more information other people
have I think I appealed to people's ego
sometimes or but I do the opposite
version which is I insult them which
it's works beautifully called Megan
Megan I'm a really good [ __ ] but I'm
really funny I'm a funny [ __ ] I don't
like I literally you know someone once
if he sees recently a facelift and
nobody was saying anything but
everyone's talking don't have been
secretly it was terrible faceless and so
and I went up to him and I went what the
hell's going on with your face and he
goes what are you talking about and I
said you had a facelift clearly and
everyone's talking about it I'm just
asking because I'm curious why you did
that's horrible thing to your face and
he's like I never had a face if I might
come on stop like please stop what are
you doing and so it I will do stuff like
that and I think people either like it
like because I don't I'm not like purely
like I don't cut them down but when they
say something dumb to me I immediately
go you've gotta [ __ ] be kiddin me that
you just said that or I was with a with
a tech Titan from your book Titans I
don't know if he was one of the Titans
you talked about but I've known this
person for years and you've done a lot
of people before they were billionaires
right your sock is one that I know there
are many years um I did one I'll tell
you the one I did with him he goes we
were at a party I don't even think he
remembers this but he was whenever he'd
introduce my him to me I go I'm sorry I
don't remember you and I did and he go
Chris for psycho we met I'm like I'm
sorry I'm just like like I blamed on
myself I pulled oh Willy Wonka yeah I
just in he fell for it all the time he
finally caught on I thank all too man
and then I stopped doing and I just
thought it was funny because it's so
easy you know we're like you go to
someone and was like oh I went Harvard
and I go where's that okay and they're
like Boston I go oh MIT is a great
school and they're like no Harvard I'm
like I'm oh yeah I've heard of it like
do you know naming it's Harvard people
always tell you so I do it's stuff like
that and a lot of it I do try to knock
them down to size cuz I think what
happens with Silicon Valley people
who've gotten well they who I knew
before that they get licked up and down
all day they really do come on let's you
know what I mean like oh you're so
oh and they never think they're wrong
and they never can be challenged and I
was with another one the other day and
they I said no I don't agree what's
wrong like and by the way I was right
and so they're like well uh and I'm like
you know I know you get agreed with all
day long but you know you're not always
[ __ ] right like I'm sorry I knew you
before when you were a normal person and
nobody was kissing your ass all day so
I'll get back to the tektite and so we
were talking it I think was a TED or
something like that which I which I
sometimes like part of it I like I like
a lot of it but there's a lot of self
actualization going on aggressively and
in it there's a lot of smart self back
patting yeah yeah like aren't we great
well he over privileged people and and
so he started doing the downward-facing
dog in front of me I was having a
conversation
this is just for conduct yeah this is
not in an ashram or you know it was like
where the water was and in the steel
bottles like the area of steel bottle
water really because this plastic was
horrible and so so he started doing
while I was talking yoga and I like yoga
and there's an appropriate place to do
yoga but I was looking at his ass and
he's horrible Juicy Couture PS it I was
like what are you doing and like he's
like what are you talking about and I
said you don't you know let's finish our
conversation and then you can do your
stupid downward-facing dog it's fine
he's like well no one seems to mind I go
hits cuz you're a billionaire and they
don't tell you you're an [ __ ] but
you're an [ __ ] don't do a
downward-facing dog in front of someone
especially ask facing I know that it was
like it was so like but he had lost all
perspective of behavior like he cuz
everybody tolerates it cuz they want to
get on his plane or they want to get
they want something from them and I
think the last part in that vein is I
don't want things from people I don't
want their I don't need their love I
don't need their money I don't need
their acceptance or anything like that
and so I was with another guy who who's
a big deal in Hollywood and he's like
you want to come to my party I'm like no
I really like you know and I didn't I
wasn't doing it on purpose I wasn't
interesting going to his party you guys
would you want to meet this star and I'm
like no and he's like you wanted me this
dog like no like I don't need to go to
their house I don't get doesn't help my
life and literally they he goes there's
nothing I have you
is there and I go now no I don't want to
prostitute like there's nothing I
thought like it was like it was funny
and so I I think being really self-aware
about things that you don't like don't
get sucked into it it's been really
effective and so if they don't have
anything to hold over you you really do
have a lot of power it's a huge amount
of leverage yeah do you have you always
cared so little what people think yes
that's exactly what you're talking about
I was gonna say you know I think being
gay has given me that gift in terms of I
don't think it's formed everything about
me but again I grew up in an era where
there was a lot of pushback and
rejection and so you either had to say I
like Who I am and I'm gonna keep doing
that and then just not care and so it
sort of created a situation where if I
cared what people thought about me being
gay I would have been just crushed and
then I just didn't care about that and I
thought it was actually quite nifty like
wow I'm better than you kind of thing
and so just I think it started there it
really did explain you I was gay when I
was four and I was super happy with it
and I stayed happy with it and I think a
lot of gay people of that era of my ear
I'm just I was at the cusp of it being
accepted with a lot of struggle and
people before me they had went through
terrible times because it's the only
thing your family rejects you know if
you're black or Jewish people get
anti-semitism of racism
your family does but your family is the
one on the attack many of time many
times for people and so I think it
started with that and then I think I was
just like that I just didn't care what
people thought of me I don't know why
and it's it's unusual for a woman to
because women are particularly pleasing
tried good girl try to be pleasing
person and I'm always pressing people
not to do that especially women like I
always say I have a thing where a lot of
people come to me and ask about jobs or
was they should do or something I try
really hard to be mentors to people
because I had a lot of great mentors and
I hate that word
and I always say they always come to me
like someone came to me recently and
said I've gotten this job offer in this
job offer in this job offer and I said
what do you want to do and they said
what this job offers interesting and I
was like I'm not asking I didn't ask you
that question I asked you what do you
want to do and
well this job I said no no that's like
what's being offered to you this that's
over the transom right like that's not
it's like being in a restaurant and they
say we have chicken we've got pork we
got beef then you can have one of those
and would you want spaghetti like maybe
he wants [ __ ] spaghetti and so it was
really interesting and they were like oh
I never thought it was like why are you
taking what's handed you what would you
like to do and at every point in my life
where I have said what pleases me I
always get more successful I don't know
if you think this but you don't you
don't I don't like to take what's
offered to me oh I think that and you
know who who made this point to me has
made this point to be over and over in
is Matt Mullenweg yeah and when someone
says do you want a or B goes well it's a
false dichotomy right or why not C or D
or E right and I agree one percent I
think that if you're constantly choosing
from the multiple-choice test right it
does and people do that it's amazing you
sort of fall into relationships like who
offered you a date like who like instead
of what do you most people have gone out
with I've decided I'd like to go out
with him you know what I mean like it
wasn't as if like it's not for what the
kind of person I wanted the kind of
thing and I think it's really it's it
limits your choice essentially but at
the same time if you I'll never forget
when I walked out of a building once I
was working on the book about AOL I was
in New York which would be one of those
beautiful spring days and it had been
working at the Washington Post and it
was on this trajectory to go way high
there I was doing super well and I had
taken the time to write this book on AOL
at the beginning of the Internet and
beginning of digital stuff and I
remember walking out and it was bright
bright bright and I and I thought and I
really believe in these moments and I
think people have to pay attention to
them and I I thought I have to leave the
Washington Post I have to leave like I
didn't know it was just a pivot it was
it a pit for me and it wasn't like God
like bull it wasn't like that it was
like it's time to go I got to do
something else I'm not gonna grow and I
remember thinking everyone in the
building was in the same seat and they
weren't going anywhere and I remember
thinking going in like nobody's moving
and I have to move I have to go and same
thing when we left the journal it was
like I gotta go it's time to go it's not
it's not I want to do something else
that's better for me I'm becoming
difficult with people I started to get
super rude to my bosses which I do
periodically so I thought I shouldn't
have a boss not having a boss is a good
idea because it makes me a lesser person
and and I don't like their opinions kind
of so if you say had a doesn't have to
be a woman but you mentioned having had
mentors if woman came up to you or one
of your sons for that matter it make
cared too much about what other people
thought I hate that and they asked for
help though they said what should i do
how can I train myself mm-hm
what would you say to them well you know
what's interesting I just had this
conversation with someone very close to
me yesterday about two days ago about
this because they were talking about how
social media informs them too much and
how they they said I wonder if I'm more
influenced by the outside or the inside
and I'm worried I'm more you know like
photos on Facebook or people being happy
and and we discussed this issue before
and he's absolutely true that's exactly
what was happening and so you know I was
like those pictures are not real it's
not what you know people that's their
best side like that doesn't mean what's
actually going there's lots of
unhappiness in there and there's lots of
not just necessarily in happiness but
it's not true that's the photo it's not
the true true thing that's happening and
so I always just cuz I'm a reporter I
know that's not the real story and so
I'm always thinking that people are
that's the next thing I use a lot when I
was a young reporter I used to think
what are people lying to me about and
then to become a great reporter what are
people lying themselves about every day
what do they need to lie about to get
through the day and so I think that's
the stronger thing and I think people do
that all the time and I think I tell
myself the truth a lot like that's not
true
I'm not feeling that I'm like today I
was mad at someone I was like I'm
[ __ ] pissed like I think most oh
don't be pissed don't be you know and so
what I tell my sons cuz I'm one of my my
oldest son is a real pleaser I really
don't like found him he's really worried
about people you know he's a teenager I
get it but I I was like with this parent
person thinks about you you are never
twenty years from now you're gonna
remember that person and it doesn't
matter what they think about you and you
will see it's hard to see into the
future but I promise you what this
person said about you doesn't matter
even slightly for a second and so I
don't know how you
get out of it if you start to realize
that your best instincts is first
yourself and then people you really
trust and even people you trust don't
give you you know what I mean like great
advice sometimes if you trust in your
own self you often can not feel bad when
people come after you I was chatting
just yesterday with this gent I had been
hoping to talk to you for decades dr.
Phil Zimbardo he's a professor emeritus
at Stanford he ran the Stanford Prison
Experiment like 70 well I want to talk
to you just no no I needed to reamed of
speaking with him for decades but hadn't
pursued him he's gonna sound bad I
thought he was dead oh yeah he's 83 he's
83 he's not dead he's very much alive
and busier than ever but he researches
and writes a lot about how to mitigate
damaging conformity and subservience to
power and he brought up this exercise
that he calls his he calls a deviant for
a day and he said just get an erasable
black marker draw a square on your
forehead and walk around all day and
resist the pressure that you're gonna
get from everyone to take it off and
yeah he's a series of exercise it's a
great idea and it reminded me of what
Kato thousands of years ago used to do
who he was considered the perfect stoic
by Seneca but he would wear for instance
a tunic so you were clothing that was of
an unfashionable color to elicit
ridicule from other people deliberately
to develop an immunity yeah and he did
that just routinely to develop that
tolerance yeah I do that myself I wear
boys t-shirts I like them and so a lot
of people like my mom all these people I
go oh why do you dress I'm like [ __ ] you
I like it and they're like well I'm like
no no [ __ ] you I like it I'm gonna wear
and I think part of me I wear it because
it bothers people sometimes or my
glasses I wear my sunglass and I have
super bad eyes and I can't wear I have
dry eyes so I can't wear contacts it's
more information than you need but and I
have light sensitivity a little I just
don't like bright lights and so I wear
my sunglasses a lot of places and
they're always a v8 errs which people
know me for and people are often they
constantly have to comment when I have
them on
do you have that mom like this I do and
they don't they expect me to take them
off like that mentally what can't take
him off him like no I can't
like photographers like well can't take
off for a second I go no I can't like
and they're not used to people not being
cooperative like and it's it's really
interesting because I really like not
being cooperative it's something I don't
want to do and and you know I make jokes
now I'm like I'm trying to avoid
intimacy like you know stuff like that
so they'll get the [ __ ] off my case but
I'm like I'm not taking off my [ __ ]
losses it's not happening it's not it's
not but it's really interesting how
quickly pressure like how quickly you do
to pressure and I think I have a I
almost feel sometimes that I'm somewhat
too rude like it's not a New Yorker
thing I'm from New York but it's not
that I just people try to really impose
their opinions on you almost continually
and I just I have this things that
sometimes I say things and I literally
say something like oh did I just say
that out loud like you're an [ __ ] and
I'm sort of like whoa I just said it out
loud and so I think sometimes I should
not do that
sometimes a few things to underscore
number one I will defend your Wolverine
shirt any day isn't it great coming out
Logan I love and I was so worried about
that guys for a second since you brought
please was so worried as a devout comic
book nerd for my entire upbringing that
they were gonna cast somebody terrible
for Wolverine then when they got Hugh oh
I don't like when they make them cute
though I like him like really under No
rough and surly yeah I'm excited about
this next one I watched those over and
over again knows I love the movies so
the last one wasn't so good sadly yeah
Hugh Hughes him up he was a machine
the question I would ask is you
mentioned the soccer story you mentioned
a few things that the downward-facing
dog story yeah god I'll never forget
that ass that seemed to reflect and I'd
love for you to correct me if this isn't
accurate but an ability to throw people
off of autopilot mm-hmm that I would
imagine helps you do what you do yeah
absolutely I do I knock the I do it on
purpose I do it I do it naturally I
don't think I do it I don't calculate it
in a story written about me in New York
Magazine Marc Andreessen called it
Stockholm Syndrome
like people you learn to love your
captors yeah they love they he goes I
don't understand she literally would
call me up and make me insecure and
angry and I tell her exactly what she
wants to know and I steals I think it's
a Stockholm so I'm not sure what's
happening but you know I think I think
they don't get challenged a lot of them
you know what I mean like and but then I
agree when they're right like I don't go
you're an idiot almost continually but I
do I think smart I've said this before
smart people like to be challenged and
they like smart people challenging them
and they if you all day you get kind of
silly stupid puffy questions you're
bored out of your mind well and if
someone doesn't agree with you you grow
like oh why don't they if they don't
know disagreement he just to be
disputatious that's different but if you
know it was it was something I think I
was having a meeting with someone at
Google about Twitter or something I was
just asking questions and they were
giving me the pap smear you know perhaps
my oh my god that's a terrible words but
you know the Pat like Oh like but and I
was like all right you don't believe any
of that right likes can we get to the
actual thing and and it was really funny
that minute I did that you think it gave
him permission to act like a real person
you know what I mean and I wasn't gonna
the other thing I don't do is I don't
use everything I talk I will talk off
the record with people for hours and
stuff and I don't use it I file and way
for later I don't like sneak up on them
I think one of the things that's really
effective for a great reporter is they
see me coming they don't I don't I'm not
a sneaky I don't there's no reason I
mean I tell them exactly what I'm gonna
do here's what I'm gonna do the only
person I haven't been able to do that
with his Marissa Mayer who won't speak
to me which but to her detriment
she should have spoken to me well
they've been a fruit I've been accurate
yeah what I think in the was this in the
New York Magpies when they talked about
how Yahoo's been able to chart their
stock price well they've been accurate
pieces like sure recently the we broke
the story about the pipe broke the story
about the breach the first breach and I
heard about it and this was this isn't
some dumb company she bought and
frittered away ten million dollars which
I offends me as a shareholder too but
this was a serious breach of people's
privacy and everything else and so I
called them and they never call back
which was which has drives me crazy like
it is they could say you know I can't
even say no comment and so I called them
at night I left a message for a PR
person and I said listen this is [ __ ]
serious I was like this isn't like a
game I'm playing right now this isn't a
dumb little acquisition this isn't
someone leaving this is five hundred
million people affected you need to
respond to me you absolutely have to and
if you don't like as they had written me
an email it was like we we can't respond
we can't wasn't no comment we can't risk
you know we it was some weird comment I
said I'm gonna print this entire email
exchange if you do not call me back cuz
I'm gonna show how ridiculously badly
you're managing your company because
this is not a little thing this is a
material issue and they did respond
finally I was just kind of pissed off
and so I I really don't we try really
hard to get them to respond and to get
them to react to things we think are
accurate and by the way everything we've
written has been accurate and it's
turned out exactly the way we said it
was because we spend a lot of time
analyzing and thinking about how it's
gonna go and I think non-engagement
non-response is really the worst thing
anybody can do to someone like me how do
you as a very smart very strong-willed
person elicit honest feedback from
people or perhaps put another way who do
you rely on to tell you when you're on
me yeah lots of people I listened I do
listen oh no I'm sure you listen I just
okay I can imagine people being
intimidated right he surprised people's
will I think because I'm forthright they
become more forthright I think people
don't like they suddenly get like oh ok
real talk right so I often one one
phrase I use a lot when they say
something to me that I think is just not
accurate or untrue or it's sort of
half-assed and I say I don't believe you
and nobody said what what do you mean
you think I'm lying like no I just think
you're not telling the truth
and so which is the same thing right and
and I think once they start to do they
do calculate that they they have things
to say and I don't think I think people
were you give I apologize for energy and
could you give an example of when you
might use that I don't believe you
Oh with Steve Jobs all the time he was
he had they had gone after a blogger
over something some memo you know what I
mean that had gotten leaked or something
it was active
was accurate but they went after this
small little blog who had written about
it's McKinney remember at the circle you
never remember the circumstances he's
dumb Christ like crazy crisis at the
time but they had gone after internal
memo or they'd gotten something but they
were really attacking this small thing
and the issue was the thing was totally
accurate that that pissed me off it was
accurate it wasn't like they did
something wrong or something like that
and he I was on stage asking about this
and he said well you know we have
internal people we have other things and
he and I said would you have done that
to me
and he's like what and I go if I had
done it would you have done it to me and
Walt and he was like no and I said so
you're doing it because they're weak and
you can get them right and he's like yes
you know it was but he couldn't there
was no other way to put it he wouldn't
have done it to me and a place where I
didn't do it this year and I regret it
every minute I was interviewing Sheryl
Sandberg at code this year it was about
Peter teal going after Gawker and I felt
like you know I don't agree with what he
did obviously and I didn't like the
secret nosov it I thought if that was if
he really felt that way he should have
done it publicly you know and not giving
us lectures about journalism and then
did it on the sly because if he hadn't
won you never would have heard he did
you know that so I was like the
secretiveness really got to me and also
Facebook is supposedly friends to
publishers and here's one of their board
members killing off a publisher that
didn't just have one property they had
ten property and hundreds and hundreds
of employees working at other places she
had no thought to that right he just
wanted to punish this one property in
this in this media group and this one
man Nick Denton and so I just wish
you've been honest about what he was
doing you know what I mean like I'm an
[ __ ] I'm gonna go after the Rich's
[ __ ] you know what I mean or whatever
just something that was just a little
more honest and I was interviewing
Cheryl and she said Peter has this has
nothing to do with him being on the face
but it's his thing that he's doing
that's what she said
you know maybe the perfect sheryl
sandberg answer she's real good at them
you know she's she sort of answers and
yet it's not really an you know what I
mean it's part she's fantastic and her
control self control of herself and what
I should have said right then is would
you have done it because they've
attacked you a lot would you have done
it I think I would have caught her like
I think it would have tripped you'd have
been like she would have had to say no
yeah she'd have to say no and I want it
I should have gotten on the record
saying no I would not have so that would
have been kind of even if I hated them I
wouldn't have done it so I think that
would have that was a missed opportunity
she mentioned Steve Jobs mm-hmm I'd love
to get your take on what the components
of a reality distortion field are or
charisma just more broadly speaking
he definitely kruseman is what I'd say I
think people like to do that reality
surgery because you don't have to
believe him like everyone's like oh I
had to believe he had some magical kind
of like mojo I I didn't find him that
way at all he was just doing his thing
and he was better at it than other
people you know I think he was um he was
persuasive I would say and he was
charismatic aggressively charismatic I
guess he was also certain all the time
you know what I mean whatever he would
say one time on stage he said I said are
you gonna do Walter I said are you gonna
do a phone and he said absolutely not
I'm not good at jumping through jumping
through orifices which is a great word
you know he had thought about it like
cuz you know come up with orifice easily
and and it was like I don't like to jump
through [ __ ] that's really what he
was saying in a really clever way and
literally in the next year he introduced
the iPhone so it was like you're a
[ __ ] liar like you and we we were
like you lied he's like I did I mean it
was like he didn't hide it like I didn't
lie but he didn't even go I didn't lie
precisely he knew what he did because
they'd been working
they'd been clearly working on it so but
he went out of his way to lie like that
was my favorite part and so um
people sometimes got offended but I
didn't care like he was a showman he was
you know didn't matter I think one of
the things that people got wrong about
him and you know he was difficult I
didn't work with him so I didn't know
you know he definitely had a temper and
had opinions and very strong opinions it
could be very cutting but soaking a lot
of people I don't think he was any more
than anybody else necessarily he's just
more famous and therefore people noted
but he I used to think you know people
were like he was heartless they always
said he's heartless heartless I think he
had too much heart that's you know what
I mean like he cared too much and so he
had so much heart that he just couldn't
stand it when things weren't right and I
think that was more of it when I started
looking him that way it made a lot of
similar sense to me and I again I didn't
know him personally very well I knew him
by interview in eight or nine ten times
and Walt knew much better but I think he
just had a lot of heart and it was
overwhelming to him me a lot of feelings
and he never hid them and one time when
we were backstage together I hit just
ahead had I of a son and my partner
Megan at the time we both with two kids
same father we each had a baby and he
asked a lot of questions about it like
whoa do you know the father do you know
it like it was unusual and most tech
people don't ask me personal questions
and he was really curious and I then I
realized of course he was foster he was
a [ __ ]
he was adopted and he had lost his he
didn't know his parents and this was he
told the story of what happened about
finding his father not liking his father
this is way before the watch Isaacson
book and he took there was a fascinating
story that he told better than ever was
told after he died about how he found
his parents and he said you know your
your your parents are not and he talked
about hurting his parents being hurt but
his adoptive parents being hurt by his
seeking the parents which is totally
understandable and that your your
biological parents aren't necessarily
your parents it was this whole thing it
was fascinating and and that you should
not should incur the father necessarily
and it was it was so unusual I wasn't
unwelcome it was really interesting
because I didn't know him that well but
it was he was so passionate and
heartfelt about it and then he hugged us
all it was so strange and I think he was
probably in an emotional period around
his illness at the time but it was
really fascinating because he was like
your parent isn't your parent and you
should not think that and one of the
things that struck me I'll never forget
he talked about how he was the only the
good thing that came out of the met his
sister his full sister for this parents
had had a child after they put him up
for adoption and you really got insight
into him because you thought they never
went back for him did they you know they
had another kid so it was even more
troubled and so you do understand that
I've had to inform I mean maybe he would
poo poo that but I think it had to
inform him the anger of not being being
left behind and interestingly enough he
was very close friends with Larry
Ellison who had a similar experience
with his mother who left him with he
told me a story of that and it was
really I do spend a lot of time thinking
about people's past like and how it
impacts them going forward I I never met
Steve but I heard a story that reflects
him being man of strong emotions but at
points that really caring for people he
this is from an old-timer at Apple I was
at I was in Cupertino and he said I see
that ATM over there you're having a
launch oh yeah I see the ATM was at one
point since there was a story going
around about Steve
because this extremely overweight guys
300 something pounds was getting money
out of the ATM and he heard what are you
doing to yourself you're killing
yourself and he turned around it was
Steve Jobs yeah and Steve said this is
my office's number I want you to call
we're getting you a trainer you can't do
this to yourself
yeah I love that I don't mind that I
didn't mind it I mean you know he
definitely had difficulties and there's
all kinds of people like to tear people
down he didn't hide his he didn't fake
anything like he never pretended he
wasn't kind of an [ __ ] sometimes
so I kind of like that I like people
like that and so people always say oh he
wasn't as big a hero I said I don't
think he's a hero
I think he's fascinating like it's even
we tend to try to like cartoon eyes
people you know what I mean and not make
them complex and let them have
complexity and I think one of the
reasons I again others I'm a good
reporter I understand complexity and
that there's a lot of different
personalities at once and I love that I
did that recently I was in a I say
things right out loud again I was at an
airport someone in front of me was who
was overweight was and I shouldn't
offense but I wasn't calling them fat
just didn't want them to do it and they
said okay so what do you want to go I'm
not gonna have the the cruller I'm give
me the muffin cuz it's healthy and I
wouldn't no it's not and they're like
what I said it's full of sugar carbs I
said it's so much more color candy bar
just get the candy bar if you want sugar
just get the [ __ ] candy bar it's
better it's taste better you don't want
that bran muffin because it sucks for
you
and I was like and and she's like what
it's not your business I said no I just
don't want you to like don't eat it like
do like please just have the cake I know
you want sugar so go for it and I wasn't
ant I'm like I'm not anti sugar and it
should be anti sugar but it was like
really fascinating and I just literally
was I did the same thing and I'm
thinking I gotta shut up then I didn't
want her to eat it like you know what I
mean cuz I could see like the steps you
know so I kind of like that that he did
that have have you ever hit someone too
hard in coverage or stories never no not
physically
get it story and and regretted it or run
sang no no okay no no no no I actually
do hold back I mean a good one Marissa
Mayer is I new member with that story
when she slept through the meeting got a
ton of thing I had that story I didn't
write it I thought she might be pregnant
I've been tired and pregnant before I
thought she just overslept I thought it
was sexist cuz a lot of Google male
executives skipped meetings all the time
and nobody gives a [ __ ] I've held back
on story so I always want to help back
on she never know that but I thought it
was it wasn't same thing with a lot of
that stuff around herd evenness like
calling her Evita I never came across
that nor what I write it you know what I
mean I wouldn't I tend to anything
that's personally not pertinent I don't
put in like and I know a lot of stuff so
I do I think no I actually don't do the
hits i i will only hit on their
financial performance every now i can
make a joke you know what I mean like
Jerry Yang I said raise the tent yang
tannic like I have funny headlines but
you know it's they're funny they're
meant to be funny not necessarily cruel
I don't think I don't think anything
I've written is necessarily cruel I
don't know anything might know just
through yeah I don't I I have to go back
I'm sure someone could find something
any trumple thin-skinned is funny you
don't he I think it's funny it's funny
so I tend to go for funny more than
stuff like that and you know I think
people I just did a recent piece about
Peter to when he was giving that idiotic
speech at the National Press Club and
everyone just typed it like just typed
what he said and I didn't I said he says
this and he you know he talks about
privacy and he's invested in his money
is made from two of the most privacy
attacking companies around Facebook and
felt like come on like like let's just
give some context so I think I don't
think I let people get away with things
I don't think I'm turn the goings cruel
I can't think of them no do you remember
the first the first piece the first
story that you were involved with where
you thought to yourself I think I gave
it really be good at this I think I
could do this full yeah I mean what was
there a moment a lot of them I was
pretty good and I won the sounds crazy I
won something called the bun award
the UN best buns in college when I was a
freshman in the newspaper was won by a
senior and I wanted as a freshman and I
remember thinking yeah I'm really good
like was the would you I wrote a columns
I wrote columns at college life and
stuff like that they were funny and they
were pointed and you know I didn't let
the Jesuits get away with as much as
other people did and so I think I think
when I called The Washington Post it's a
pretty famous story of me calling Larry
Metro edit at the time and I had covered
a story that they had covered and theirs
was full of errors and it made me mad I
called him and said you suck I could do
it and you go do you think you could do
better I said I absolutely good and I
went down and I got a job I mean iured
me on the spot so that kind of thing
worked out well sometimes I think I
wrote a series of stories for the
Washington Post that and Ben Bradley
loved them so that was like the best
thing ever talk about crack you know
having him come over and go great job
kid like this is my dream and it wasn't
Watergate but I was writing about a
family reached a covered retail and
there was a family in Washington called
a half's and I did a great job covering
their fighting was like I wrote it like
King Lear like it was King Lear and so I
did do it was a great job I really got
to the emotions and the complexity and
power and money and there was sex
involved and so it was a great story I
wrote it that way and I remember and it
was my natural instinct to do it like
young reporters didn't do that and I
remember him saying he wanted to know
every day what the next chapter was and
I I began to see that I was super good
at narrative which I think reporters
aren't they don't think of it as a long
going story so I approached a lot of
stories like narratives I'm like what's
the next chapter and so when he would
come in every day and say what's what he
got for me today like he wanted to know
I thought that was a really powerful way
to tell stories so I thought it was good
at from the beginning if you were and
maybe you've taught I don't know if and
I apologize but if you were to teach a
college freshman seminar in journalism
or writing teacher but yeah I did I
taught at Berkeley and I was terrible
why were you terrible and because I was
like they didn't know how to do it like
tell you I learned them all by myself no
one taught me like I'm a terrible person
I'm just the worst teacher I'm just it's
just not my nature okay
I could take a different angle right if
you were to recommend okay and eat any
books yeah any books to people who are
aspiring writers or journalists are
there any that come to mind
um it's drunken White's The Elements of
Style as always I reread it over a year
it's a great book is still is
I think anything by Joan Didion in the
earlier slouching towards Bethlehem the
White Album part two of my favorite
books touching towards Bethlehem I read
over and over and over again like three
or four times a year it's so beautifully
constructed
um she said why's she also taught she
involves herself in the stories a little
bit more and and and has a has a very
descriptive I I am I'm remembering when
you said what do you remember I remember
I wrote a story about this company in
Washington when I was at the Washington
Post about a really expensive we just
all of a sudden these luxury grocery
stores were getting started and this was
not a thing many men now they're
everywhere but I covered retail and I
said and my lead which they didn't want
to keep but I insisted on was here in
the land of the $4 tomato and I loved it
that was funny it was wasn't it and the
the best leader ever wrote and I'll
never write a better leader than this
again I knew mandala people didn't want
me to put it on there so I trusting my
own instincts on what people like I was
reading about discovery which had just
gotten started in Washington the
Discovery Channel this was many years
ago I found it was a guy named John
Hendricks and he he founded it he was
trying to get on cable systems and it
was all about how he tried to get on
cable systems and it's a time it's super
super hard yet real and john malone and
stuff like that that's kind of boring
dry story and i said what would spend
the secret to your success i act like
you do i ask what's been the thing
that's worked for you and he goes
sharks and Nazis Nazis and sharks thank
God for Nazis and sharks because they
have not seat we can not see and I made
that delete charts and Nazis Nazis and
sharks thank God for Nazis and it was
literally the best quote I've ever
gotten
I'll never get a quote like that it was
no it was like sharks but the Dexter
position of Nazis and sharks and not
people love Nazi document you know you
can't get enough Nazi documentaries
right people can't there's something
with Nazi documentaries and child movies
in general you gotta watch them and then
sharks the same thing so they had Shark
Week and so then I got into the Hat what
happened when Shark Week and Nazi Week
happen so from a business point of view
but it was um it was that was super good
no super good day but a lot of people
didn't want me to do it which was
interesting and it the same thing
happened at The Wall Street Journal
years later there was a guy named Greg
Zachary who really helped me there he
probably doesn't remember but I had I've
been trying to to to differentiate
myself so I wrote a story about I was
trying to get to the culture of Silicon
Valley and this nobody was covering
Silicon Valley then in the early in
nineteen ninety five six something like
that seven maybe and I was trying to get
to the culture because I thought the
culture was super important not just the
business stories the drive Yahoo today
earns much money and I wrote every where
I went
they'd all to things they did one was a
whenever I'd go out with me take me a
crappy taco place so he never take me a
real restaurant I was like what is wrong
with these people and so I wrote a story
about their favorite places to eat like
this is an unusual culture they're not
like unlike Hollywood moguls or Wall
Street moguls these people eat a taco
joints the scene is fog is no but it was
taco joints and so I did a whole thing
of taco joints that they at least
up-and-coming Marc Andreessen or Jerry
Yang law or Joe Kraus at the time and
excite and then I wrote another one
about their idiotic titles they had to
put on themselves I said I thought it
reflected them like a lot they had like
chief Yahoo or chief experience officer
you know how those demonstrators they
had a bunch of dumb [ __ ] titles and
so I wrote a story and the journey
wasn't quite like the journal to do that
they were much more you know I mean and
great just lied and got him in like
we're gonna publish these and we're
gonna tell them it was approved you know
what I mean like he was a pretty
powerful reporter at the time and
I learned a lot from that like fuck'em
you're gonna like shove that thing right
in there and so I like that I like he
was really helpful to me in that what
you've been involved with a lot of live
events mm-hmm
what makes a great event what's theater
people don't think of it as theater you
know I'm a big theater fan I used to
write a column about theater for the
Washington Post on the side I love the
era when I went from when I was a kid my
mom took me to all kinds of live events
and especially Broadway and stuff like
that any favorite shows all of them
there's nothing I don't like on stage
well that's not true there was a
rollerblading show that Andrew Lloyd
Webber did that was just awful but it
was good in its ridiculousness you know
I love angels in America I've seen it
dozens and dozens of times I loved every
iteration of Angels in America and it
was long it remember it was three hours
or whatever I love I did like Hamilton a
lot I was not expecting I was expecting
it not to be as good as I thought it was
wonderful it was very traditional or
even though it's rap it was a
traditional musical I like everything I
like stage work a lot and so I think
about again the narrative of a
conversation like you're not a lot of
people ask a question get an answer ask
a question get an answer I have a
conversation and it's a narrative
conversation and not a like it's
storytelling it's I do I come at
different ask questions that people
don't expect like and questions that
people want to know and I know it's not
Oprah like but it sees real good she's
she's really she's an amazing
interviewer and you know one time was
Steve Jobs I'll never forget and I think
people remember it to this day this
question she she go he he said something
in and it was right near the end right
here we did the interview months before
he died and he was quite it was
interesting so you'd see him better and
worse over the years at code if you look
at the pictures there's one year where
he's quite has had some weight on him
another year in the last year he was
just skeletal and it was sad but at the
same time he had more vibrance than
anybody on that stage I'll tell you that
that was what was really striking and a
lot of people when someone's dying or
sick party pretend that's not what's
happening do you don't I mean like let's
pretend you're not very very ill here
and I asked two questions I thought
people did remember and I said
what do you do all day what's the Steve
Jobs day like I just wanted to know I
just was like he's gonna be dead soon or
he looks very sick and what what does he
do all day like you were asking like
about people's what do they do the first
10 2016 is a day I wanted to know what
does he do is he get up does he eat
breakfast ly and he answered it it was
great it was like it was really great
and and then um and then I asked what
are you gonna do with the rest of your
life and everyone was like huh sharp
intake of breath like can't you Cara
that's insensitive I was like I want to
know what and he had a wonderful answer
it was about television of all things he
wanted to change television and it was
so great that he said he had that
ambition when it was possibly clear he
was Cano's when people are gonna die but
he looked real ill and so he just
started to come alive talk about
television how to change television he
was great it was like Kent and you know
Walt is familiar when he talked to my
the phone right here before he died he
was still talking about how it pissed
him off and it was great he lived right
up until he died and so I really like
not asking the questions that you really
want to know
I think reporters people on stage don't
do that and so you know when I want to
know something I'm just curious you know
and I also treat them like people not
put ten dates you know what I mean like
like I imagine every day they have
problems like I do and so I think I
don't I don't treat I'll treat the
president the same as I would a janitor
them interviewing so and I don't and I'm
not rude to the janitor I'm not rude to
the president and and so that's one
thing that's useful do you have any
particular routines or habits rituals a
yearly basis otherwise yeah
unfortunately you know we were just
talking before on my podcast about you
know picking up the phone I got to stop
that I know I feel it I feel that I'm
really wasting my time it's addictive
and I'm not an addictive personality I
don't drink I don't take drugs we all go
to sex but but it's that's possibly the
most part of my personality but I don't
I have to stop it's it's sucking time
away you know and that's such a cliche
but it truly is there's something
happening to my brain that's getting
rewired and dopamine I think it must be
that right
I mean it's the others dopamine involved
there's also serotonin involved in safe
social media hits and so on it doesn't
feel good it's not a feel-good feeling
it's not it's not pleasing so like when
you have a cookie I'm happy like it's
kind of interesting or something or ice
cream like you know you can like when I
kid for the first time I'll never forget
giving him ice cream for the first time
you know he tasted it and you could see
his what what oh my god like you could
see the it was like physical it was
mental it was everything you don't get
pleasure from this stuff I'm not happier
like it's it's entertaining and it's
addictive and so I feel like I have to
stop that I've got to figure out how to
do it because I do have a job where
people do have to get in touch with me
and sometimes immediately so I'm trying
to figure out like the ding-ding of your
phone like I try to turn on the thing
and I don't want to hear from people and
I think I've got to correct things
because I fill up my days way too much
like I feel like I'm over scheduled no
you you may be over scheduled at the
same time you've been extremely
effective very your work and what and
you're clear I'm super productive and
you've made choices along the way to
break from certain things start new
projects always I always break so how do
you choose well if you could walk us
through your thought process how you
choose which projects to take on or
which to say no to well it's interesting
I think people go through maybe you
disagree this people go through creative
periods I agree do you know what I mean
like set this month I'm really creative
I don't know what happened might have
started a column and it's really good
and someone just said what happened to
you and there's some things that went on
in my life but I don't know what it's
just I do know I have some ideas but
it's it's um it's really interesting to
go through those periods and just right
now nothing no to any idea because it's
super creative and so I feel like I'll
decide a font of really pant I have an
idea for a book finally that I like
people are always trying to get me to
write books and part of me is like oh
I'm write another book like over like
were there yahoo and then I'm like want
to shoot myself in the eye like I could
write that in my sleep but I don't want
to do it I just reclined to do it and so
I have an idea that just suddenly hit me
and I was like I'm gonna do this so I
was doing that and then we're working on
a TV show and I'm
kind of interested in it so so you're
saying they you said no to the say the
the uber or yeah I've had for the past
couple of months I get offered all the
time but if you got offered that book in
January would you have said yes
no why not what's the thought just not
stimulating myself okay I'd be bored out
of my couldn't do it you know when you
can't I actually don't do things I can't
do
years ago I had an assignment for
Glamour magazine write 10 things 10
interesting people I couldn't do it
I like refused to do it it was weird and
I was like well if I can't do what I
can't do it and it was a lot of money so
money doesn't motivate me so that's hard
and it doesn't it never did and it
doesn't anymore cuz I got plenty so it's
not like I've got to be interested in it
or it's you know sometimes I like things
guy that makes me famous I like being
famous like you know no I mean like
maybe that's my motivation alright I
like getting being notorious or whatever
is the thing that pleases me is what
what you have to respond to or that it's
an interesting puzzle or a question so
it has to like this book is it really I
want to know about it it's the thing I'm
really soon people will know what it is
but I want to know about it and that's
why I want to do it cuz I'm interested
in it and so and with a TV show I really
want to figure out how to do a TV show I
know it sounds dumb but I I love
television and I've always wanted to do
something and we have this great
relationship and easy you know there's
all kinds of opportunity that I'm not
going to get this opportunity too much
with a column I don't know why I'm Trump
and pissed about Trump I am can't stand
him and I'm not I'm trying to channel in
a way that's not quite as hateful as I
feel as many people feel because you
shouldn't react to idiots but you know
he really does there's something about
him that's an error feeling about
everything that you might dislike in
retrograde people so so I had to channel
in a really effective funny interesting
way and then with I think it comes from
you know it sounds like morbid but my
dad died when he was 34 from a cerebral
hemorrhage just died this is pretty
quickly so unexpected very very um three
kids I thought he was on his way he just
left the Navy he was poor guy Navy
putting through medical school he had
just gotten a job as head of anesthesia
at Brooklyn Jewish Hospital so it was
headed out to just bought a new house
like everything was starting
just died that was it oh um super
affected me like you can't believe like
it just creates a situation there's an
thing where people whose parents died
when they were young become highly
functional I think that since there's
actually Stanford professors written a
lot about this nothing bothers you like
war pestilence I don't care I've
survived my parents death and because
when you're that young and someone dies
it's like as if half the people you know
died right because they're the people
you depend on he was a wonderful parent
and so very attentive very loving those
are my memories and they are true
they're actually accurate and and so I
think it's always made me think I'm
gonna die young you know I mean like it
just does it's just it's not this not
there's not that much complexity to it
psychologically speaking so my brothers
and I are all incredibly successful or
very functional like we're very we
really do we don't get bogged down a lot
after I turned 34 I felt better do you
know what I mean like once I passed that
landmark but where it really hit me is
in two places one was when my son was
five and I realized how well he knew me
you know I don't remember a lot of my
fine you remember little snatches and
memories I've always wanted to get
hypnotized having better memories but
I'm not so sure that'll leave him work
but he knew me incredibly well at five
like we were very close we had
conversations so I must have had that
and I don't remember it but it was Devon
I remember being devastated at the time
you had that realization that he knew me
so well I realize how devastated I was
like oh my God look what I lost you know
what I mean so I lost that relationship
and it was more significant than I can
recall cuz I can't you tend to like just
like you can't remember you just can't
remember there's only so many things you
remember and I don't remember last week
and so I remember being very devastated
by like for him for me for me as a
five-year-old you know what I mean and I
never let myself feel that way when I
was younger most of my life and so I
really was like wow that really did hurt
me and it was a good realization like to
not just think you're not weak you know
or you got hurt and so again that's not
something I had any control over it
wasn't cruel parent it wasn't abuse it
wasn't it just was a bad thing that
happened the second thing is when I had
a stroke which is five years ago if you
know this I had a stroke in on my way to
Hong Kong
I was going for a code All Things D Asia
d Asia and I was flying in coach and
should have not been flying a coach and
I didn't get up in my seat I didn't
drink water I'm like the ad for the deep
pain throws and so I as it turns out it
also had a hole in my heart which 20% of
the human race has apparently I was told
and it's called a PF Oh interesting that
a lot of people took on how they have
them later told me they had them and
it's super common but this was like a
hole in one and it also turns out from
doing 23andme that I have and we just
get called me in Hong Kong after it
happened told me said you need to look
at your report because you have this
blood disorder this fear also very
common it's called Mediterranean blood
it's thick thick blood essentially my
family's Italian and so I had all these
things that I didn't know and they all
conspired to have a stroke I had a
stroke and I was working away we riding
about Yahoo someone had left I'm like oh
this [ __ ] place is like a disaster
and they said it out loud and it came
out garbled super garbled and I was like
that's weird now suffered from migraines
I thought it was like a migraine I was
tired and it landed and I didn't go to
sleep and and so I so I kept typing and
then I went to eat a strawberry and it
fell out of my mouth and I was like
that's weird and then I felt a tingling
and that was it that was the entire
range of symptoms I couldn't speak
strawberry finger so I couldn't call
anyone to tell anyone about this cuz I
was like boom this is odd
like I wasn't totally disturbed that I
was like this is unusual perhaps it's
just a bad headache and I wrote it
emailed my brother who's a doctor who
followed my father's footsteps and he
was asleep because the time difference
was odd it was a different time
difference and then I went up to
breakfast I took a shower it literally
didn't do anything like the worst I'm
like the ad for not what not to do when
you have a stroke and I by the time I
got to breakfast I was speaking as if I
had you know dental work ha how are you
doing so it was coming back pretty quick
less ago see it's just a weird muscle
thing and my brother called me said you
need to get to a hospital you're having
a stroke and I'm like oh come on you
terrible die like insulted and I was
like that's ridiculous I'm young you
know I was in my 40s and he's like
please just do me the favor and go get
an MRI not a cat scan tell them this
please go right now and I was like
alright
I went to the hospital and turns out I
was having a stroke which was amazing
was just like uh-huh and I was sort of
like I was outside of myself I was
having it you know and I wasn't and I
was fighting at the hospital I'm talking
like this so there was I wasn't feeling
bad it wasn't tired
there was no there were no anything
symptoms nothing but they did the cat
scan MRI and it turned out it was had I
had had one or a just finished one and
you could see what was really I was
fascinated by this I should have been so
fascinated you could see the blood going
around the clock like this it was so
cool though your body just spinning was
terrified yeah but your body fixed it
like your body found another it's like
traffic right you're in traffic and you
find another route it found another
route to get the blood through and so
and I remember it all the people in
China they have things over their faces
right all the time in the hospitals they
do which is disturbing it's sort of
weird when the doctor said you had a
stroke and it's the first time I got
upset cuz I thought about my kids
I thought my kids without me this is
gonna be horrible for them and I
remembered how horrible it was for me
and I had like flash like a trigger it
was like such an amazing I didn't get
upset any other time during the process
and I started crying just then because I
thought about my kids so it was really
it was quite a month and since then I
have been like I've always been like
this is tripled and quadrupled my
determination to do whatever I wanted to
do and keep going what would you like to
be remembered for
I think being forthright and honest I
think being I think the reason I've done
really well it's because I people are so
tired of pushing themselves down in good
ways and bad ways and I think part of
the Trump thing I hate to say I'm like
Donald Trump but of course cuz I think
he lies all the time so he doesn't lies
all the time
but I think he's sort of it right he
just is it'd pure it'd there's no
super-ego stopping anything and it's
just whatever comes to his mind he just
says sort of thing and I admire nothing
about him but I do think that's
fascinating like the ability to do it so
I'd like to be remembered for someone
who told the truth or tried to tell the
truth and tried to make people
understand things a little better
without all the the useless frippery we
go around doing do you know what I mean
you know I think that would be good I'd
like to be known as a good parent I
think I am a good parent I it's funny
because people are like oh you shouldn't
say that I'm like why I'm a good parent
like I have great kids like it's funny
cuz parent people people always want to
insult their kids it's weird yeah and
they're like you know you say how are
you kids I'm like wickets are great and
they're like oh I said no they're
remarkable kids they're wonderful
they're like oh well everyone has
problems I'm like no I don't like you
know people want you know it's funny so
I think I I'm really um pleased with my
kids I'm really our parent and Megan's
and my parenting I'm very I'm very proud
of that and they like last night my son
Alex called and he was crying over the
Obama speech is 11 and it was crying was
really crying and he was like I can't
cry I'm a guy like you know and I mean
and it was like I was so proud that he
was crying I know it sounds dumb because
he was super upset and I shouldn't be
like I didn't want him to be comforted I
want him to feel I want him to feel that
feeling of being so disappointed about
what's happened politically and it was
good for him
I was and I really loved that he felt
like he could do that that was one thing
and then my other son Louie who has a
much easier time in life in general
because he's like the happiest kid ever
no he was born happy he remains happy he
so far knock on wood and he he he and I
talked a lot he they live they live away
from me right now cuz Meghan's working
for President Obama and I go back and
forth and I miss some great deal and so
we talked a lot over the holidays and
he's 14 almost 15 so we really we really
can have great conversations and
sometimes it's dumb things but we braid
arguments and stuff like that and I say
dumb things and it just was really
lovely to talk to him because it was
really I really enjoyed spending time
with him I don't think a lot of people
enjoy spending time with her kid you
know what I mean I'd rather be with him
than other people because he's super
interesting and and has a great mind and
he I was sad about something and I
hadn't said anything to him I didn't I
don't involve him in everything like
some people tell their kids too much
stuff and I said this it's been really
nice talking you I've been a little sad
but now I feel bad it goes all he said
was I know what a great kid iq don't
mean like I thought it was really I was
very moved by it because I felt like he
was so mature that he just was he didn't
have to like over talk it he just
I know you know what I mean I know like
it was great it was all he said and I
was like I was so proud of me and him
for you know be getting to that to be a
really smart young man and he really is
what are the what are the keys to good
parenting how are you it's hard because
you'd be surprised but Megan and I are
not very hard on them on school I find
the obsession with school and
achievement to be disturbing I we do not
push that your Megan more than I do but
I really don't I'm like you don't need
to know that you don't need to know that
like I'm always like that this is
useless don't don't even bother so go
for a walk like I want them to go
outside more you know what I mean like
so I think the obsession with making
your life better through your children I
think it's really demented and you see
it all over the place you see it really
a vicarious living through your kids was
more than that the achievement like
pushing them when it's when you know
full well it doesn't matter like it most
of my school and like seriously doesn't
matter I had an argument with one of his
teachers recently they were doing some
homework assignment and and they were
like I was like this is stupid and they
were like no it's nice I'm like nobody
is trust me it's doom you don't need it
and by the way I'm more successful than
you and I'm telling you it's do so it
was it was really interesting and I tell
that to them and one of the things it
does manifest itself my oldest my
youngest sighs it is quite brilliant I
really do think he's he builds he's a
builder he mentor he's he's got some
special skills that are really quite
amazing and my other son is pretty smart
very smart very very incredibly but not
at school at school he's bored by school
and so I'm trying to think of ways to
yeah but he's like he'll do great could
probably the president like he's like
that kind of person and he got he can
get he can go from A to D in two seconds
and whatever it like it's fascinating
like cuz he could do it if he wanted to
and so I shouldn't be one of his parents
it's like you've got to try harder to
get that a like you know I mean and so
he he he meant one I hate this about him
but I love it he goes because so many of
his friends are so like tightly wound
like so tightly round at a young age and
you're sort of like don't do that don't
you have plenty of time to be tightly
around and he he got a D it was math or
something like that and he's pretty good
he can get an A he could I guess or
maybe a big it definitely could get a B
it gets yes it D and I go low e d and it
goes at least is not an F I loved him
for that it's horrible least not enough
and I go it is an F I D is an F just so
you know they don't give FS anymore they
give you up D and that's an F and he
goes like and I just was like I I can't
compliment him for that response but I
love it like I was like good for him
like [ __ ] you like you know what I mean
and I know he'll be fine so I feel like
I just don't want to get them all like
so many kids and the parents are tightly
wound like they're super ly the kids are
living like adults but I'd rather the
result here right exactly like you know
he's like what if I don't go to college
I'm like it whatever like I just I feel
like I'm people are surprised as I'm so
ambitious and so hard-working but I just
feel like I'm happy with what I'm doing
that's why I'm in this just not big
enough for achievement and there's like
so many bad like the parent there in an
East Coast school which is very tightly
route the East Coast people are just I
grew up on the East Coast I forgot I
forgot like in there just they're all
watching they're all lawyers like and
they're clearly an unhappy marriages
like you can see it you know you're like
oh really never had sex in years you
know what I mean like I'm thinking that
in my head I kind of want to say it out
loud and and so so they they're just
like it retired less about the internet
and I just was like that is not true
it's just not true like you know what I
mean like don't it's not the tools it's
you it's you and your kids and they get
over over I don't know it just gets it's
funny it's funny one that things I'll
tell the story he was he was he speak
sense nap channel at the time the oldest
ones on see on this one is not on on
these stuff right now he's not involved
in all he's not interested with my older
son snapped a lot he does a lot of
videos he likes he likes it obviously
like a lot of teens very typical and he
was involved in
they had this Instagram account where
they put post means with each other and
they joke and he did one that was not
one kid got really upset about and you
know when does a joke not become a joke
well it wasn't and so there was a hubbub
at school and that's one issue I'm very
particular on us how he presents himself
to about women about people of color all
kinds of stuff like that it's not PC
it's just like he's a
white guy in America he could be a
little nicer you know what I mean like
that's my whole thing and he's lucky
he's rich he's healthy he's tall he's
got every he's handsome like he should
be nicer like he really needs to be and
kinder and so he he had done it and and
and I I made him call the parents of the
person I made talk to the kid and stuff
like that and the school called and he
didn't mean it in a malevolent way he
didn't like I wasn't trying to say
you're an [ __ ] but I didn't want him
not to feel like he was like wrong and
and and to the school was like well you
know we don't want to be punitive here
and I go no I want to be punitive I want
him to feel the consequent a lot of time
talking about consequences with him and
because he's the teen so 11 year old
doesn't matter as much but I want him to
feel consequences of his actions always
so he understands the price of things
and when you do something I want them to
understand that that's one of the things
I don't think parents do nearly enough
definitely you know what I mean but
they're great kids they're great kids
they're fantastic and I don't want them
to feel like the last thing is special
that they're so special in California
it's the opposite problem everybody's
special yeah I mean they do you don't
have children but it's it's a I don't
but I see you've seen it like awards for
everything and stuff like that and so I
was in a meeting of I'm very
grammatically accurate I love grammar
and I was in a meeting and one of the
parents are the teachers or it was like
well you know we're all special they
said that you know I mean that that
thing like and I put my hand up I go
point fact if we're all special no one's
special I said it's a word that means
different thank you let this lady in
here again no I know exactly and they're
like they were like excuse me I go what
if everybody's special nobody is just so
you know the word special it's like
unique it's just not there's no such
thing as very unique you know if you
know just like people when people do
very unique it drives me crazy I hate
when people modify unique so he so they
were like well you know we're all
special and different like oh no no no
we're not we all know the rules and the
status symbols we know it's either money
or a job or fascinating or beautifully
creative I said everybody isn't special
and that we teach kids that everyone's
special they'll think they're special
when they're not like you know I mean
there's special things like
they're the best like little Baker or
whatever but let's set the parameters
but when you're talking about its
achievement and Welles and whatever you
are like let's just let's assume that
like that once we set the rules we can
say what who is special but we can rank
people we can we absolutely you do it
every day of your life why are you
pretending to these kids that we're not
ranking all day long and kind of stuff
and of course is it San Francisco their
minds really and I said language matters
like it matters what you say and so I
was like and I don't know I said this I
said for example like and I'm successful
so is Megan like Megan's worked at
Google and she's the cg of America
we're more special than everyone else
here on jobs probably a lot of people
here let's be honest it's like come on
we're gonna rent if you had to if you're
a gun to your head you have to rank
people here come on like and I was like
that maybe jobs or it might be money
this person over here is [ __ ] rich as
hell like they win on that one and so it
was really it was this headmaster who
having good friends this was like Oh
Cara that's like I'm just like let's
define our terms if we're gonna use that
word so carelessly so I want to switch
gears a little bit and we'll run through
what I guess I call a rapid-fire
questions they don't need a rabbit so if
you had to give a TED talk on something
you're not known for at all I gave one
of my stroke I did one of those Ted so
if you had to give another one okay but
on something you are not known for what
would you give it on my obsession with
television my life TV shows like bad
television bad television what's your
favorite bad TV show anything with
Heather Locklear well I haven't thought
of it I love her she's the best I did an
interview with her once I was so happy
one of my greatest moments of my life um
anything within that I like bad TV bad
TV actresses you know they always insult
her and they're like oh she's Sarah like
no she's brilliant at bad acting like
that kind of acting that jarrah she's
the master just like the Michelangelo if
that it's not bad acting it's bad acting
like I don't even think it's bad it's
just that like the dramatic lines and I
even love like sensitive but Viola Davis
was a really great actress she's like
gonna win the Oscar for fences and stuff
like that but she's in that show how to
get away with murder
which I love like it's a terrible
horrible show it's John Doe rhymes at
her very best like and
she she had a line that she her husband
was sleeping with a co-ed how did your
penis get in that white girl's mouth
like and she read that like she was
Lawrence [ __ ] Olivia how did your
penis get that was brilliant like I was
like so I was happy for days and I was
like she [ __ ] ate that up she took
that line and she went with it it was
the work like who wrote that line and
she didn't even like she didn't even
flinch just she did it she did that line
reading like you can't believe and I
thought I love you because like you have
no there's you can act up a [ __ ]
storm over here but over here you're
just like you're taking that you're
biting it you're going for it and I love
that mentality you've met a lot of
people yeah many many many many hundreds
but at this point certainly that are
held up on a pedestal is successful when
you hear the word successful who comes
to mind and why um
among tech people know and he across the
board mm-hmm that's a good question um I
get to tell you define the terms right
right that's why I'm leaving it open so
I'd like to hear how you define it all
right really
all right thought Steve Jobs is right I
do there's just no I thought he was he
was who he was I like someone who's like
that so I thought he was successful at
being the person he was and got and
dealing with the issues he had going
forward he could have been nicer I guess
I don't care you know I was a married to
him and so although he seemed to have
good relation with his kids I don't know
I know um of the people I'd met like I
like Pierre Omidyar I think he's a
lovely guy I think he's been very
successful and he's kind and he's I tend
to like the kinder people um I think
he's true to himself he's kind of quirky
and unusual and has unusual Tate you
know things he invests in it's all
do-gooder and I'm not a do-gooder trust
me but I like that about him I really
like I do like Sheryl Sandberg we get
along very well I mean some of us some
of the stuff I tweak are all a lot about
Lena and I always say I lean in and fall
over it's a big joke I have with her I
really I I think she's she's true to
herself again she's like she's that
seems to be the common thread yeah true
themselves I do like Mark Zuckerberg a
lot
and when I first met him I did not like
him when I first met him I didn't want
to go down there wouldn't fit was 2,000
early early and Owen Bonanno who was the
president of Facebook at the time this
was a million years ago and nothing was
successful it was in public it wasn't
doing well or was doing okay it wasn't
it it wasn't it wasn't an upward
trajectory the whole time and and he
came in the room and I said I don't
wanna meet him I heard he's an [ __ ]
like oh do I want to make another little
shitty little startup white dude like a
kind of thing and he he walked in the
room and he goes I heard you think I'm
in which I liked it and I go well I
don't know you well enough you might
very well be an [ __ ] but I really
should get to know you before I call you
an [ __ ] and it was great we had a
great talk and I like him because he
learns he seems to learn he I don't like
everything he says like this last thing
about faking is I thought he was being a
name and he said a lot of inane stuff
but I liked that he seems to learn I
like people who learn and Rosalie he is
and I like kind of it's very earnest but
I kind of like it um who else do I like
that I wasn't expecting there some of
the other day were I I walked in the
room and I expect that he was wearing
like khakis in a way that I hate like
you know what I mean those you know
sansabelt like golf man khakis and a
golf guy shirt and like oh this guy like
you know what I mean like I have an
allergy to this too after Princeton yep
but here what I was doing was like okay
he looks like a person I wouldn't like
and we had the best time I am too
blanking on who it was it was just I was
sort of like I'm like this guy he's
fantastic like I wasn't expecting to
have such a great mind and so I was
surprised and I kind of was like how
kara don't be so easily judgey so I'm
trying to who else do I like I like a
lot of people I like more people than
you think
no I don't know you dislike people yeah
I like a lot of people I like the guy in
the corner store Sammy he's fantastic
I lost the Billboard question because I
like this question if you had a huge
billboard
yeah you could put a short message on it
or an image to get it out to millions of
people what would you put on it hmm
stop stop and for you what does that
mean one of my favorite books was I love
I read a lot when once that had most
effect on me was well I took a course in
freshman year Georgetown which I didn't
love for Georgetown because I don't I'm
like but I was not I grew up in a very
progressive school and so I got there
and there were all these kids from
Catholic school they just went wild so
they drank too much and vomited and
date-rape everywhere you know it just
was I'm so sexist and so horrible and
anti-gay so it was not a great time to
be at Georgetown and I was in a course
called problem God problem problem of
God problem of God right okay it's a
great title for existentialism it's
taught by Jesuit Jesuits are amazing
when you get a great one because of its
are amazing teachers and it was perfect
I was 17 I think when I went to college
I was a little younger and I it was mind
blowing of course cuz I read Sartre
Camus Kafka all those DAG hammarskjöld
which I'm not a religious person but it
really had an impact on me because he
became he was seen as a technocratic
turned out he was quite religious any
markings I think with this book and so I
was just blown it was just so my lying
407 had never thought of these issues
and I really have impacted me I'll never
forget the first day that the course the
guy's name was father Chia fee I'll
never forget him he goes he said God's
problem with man or man's problem with
God like it was like it's true like what
is it at probably man's problem with God
is more the thing but so we read all
these texts and we read the trial one of
my favorite books I read it again and
again that's another book I really
getting in it and the first line of the
book of the trial is I think I'm not
saying it right something must if
someone must have been telling lies
about Joseph K because one because he
was arrested one fine morning it's
something like that that's the first
line everybody thinks is about
totalitarian states but it's not it's
not about Russia it's not about China
it's not about communism it's about
stopping in your life and you know it's
about stopping like being stopped being
arrested the word arrested is not
arrested here it's being stopped and
considering what you're doing and this
is a man who would not stopped and
considered what he was doing and the
last line you do get it he taught it so
well like when someone teaches you a
text really well or it shows you a
painting that you didn't understand and
then opens it up to you is really I
think that's what I do with writing
sometimes I make people think
differently like oh wait a minute I
hadn't thought of that
maybe that's the truth and so this guy
taught so well in the last part of the
book he's supposedly about to be
executed but he's not he's about he's
about to go to the execution because
he's not getting it they're trying God
is trying to get through to them but God
can't impose himself on Joseph K but he
won't hear God you know what I mean like
he it was a lot about that and it's up
and in the last part of the book there's
someone throws a window I think as he's
going to the gallows or wherever he's
getting supposedly getting killed
someone throws up in the window and puts
their arms out and it's God saying stop
like just stop for a [ __ ] second and
nobody does that and so I'd say stop do
you know what I mean like totally yeah
like nobody just a second just stop like
what you're talking about meditate in
the morning just stop what's the rush
not just what's the rush there is a rush
well there is a rush but there's not the
inner Jack I mean I have been memento
mori' all over my house it's constantly
reminded death yeah Oliver that's
important and I so I recognize the value
of time but I recognize how when I rush
or when I feel rushed I'm not present
mm-hmm I'm constantly yeah
stuck so it's the same thing with stop
no no no no everyone say yes no no no no
no no and and the best part is there's a
great line from Shakespeare I think it's
Henry the fifth maybe I waste town time
and now death time waste me I've always
loved that quote that is a it's a great
line it's a great line do you a favorite
failure meaning a failure something that
didn't go the way you hoped that set you
up for later success in some way mmm I
think a lot of relationships yeah I mean
I wish I could go back you know again
that's why I like la-la-land it was
really interesting still about mistakes
right that we make with each other I
think in work now I think I've been very
very um I haven't asked questions that I
wanted I maybe didn't move fast enough
but I think he charted the path well I
think you know I was thinking the other
day someone was talking about their
career I'm like I have time my career
beautifully like it's nowhere but up now
and then I just leave you know I mean
like I can't be I was looking about all
the interviews I've done with all the
different people over the years like
over 10
fifteen years and I could leave right
now like that's how I feel like wow I've
done a lot my body of work is excellent
I'm leaving behind all these amazing
interviews with the greatest minds of
our day like I interviewed whoever was
Edison I did that whoever was Tesla
whoever was Lincoln I did it like that
moment so I feel good on the work stuff
and the word there's some stuff I don't
want to do and try and think I could get
to another plane probably probably I
haven't tried very hard in the
relationships I should I haven't been as
smart as I should have been like it's as
I am at work so that probably in that
and I guess I guess in failure it's not
um no because when I wanted to leave the
post I left I'm trying to think of where
I didn't I always leave when I should
leave I'm good at leaving like realizing
I'm not going anywhere and stopping so
I'm good at that I think I I probably
know you're good at stopping I'm good at
stopping and saying looking around and
saying no not not this any more no more
of this and so and that's in a career
since I'm good that way with my kids so
I've been I think a great parent I think
probably I've been I don't leave quickly
enough in relationships and I think I'm
getting really good at that because you
know I just recently got separated from
Megan who I love we have a great family
but I think I did that well we did that
it was a good thing it's good for both
of us and we were much happier because
of it and I feel good that's the first
time I've gone huh hi this has to change
and I had to do with my stroke too when
you stop and leave say the post or a
given publication company or a
relationship is there a way you frame it
to the other side when you have that
conversation yeah I do yeah it's it's
this is it I think what interesting with
the relation that was interesting I'm
sure Megan doesn't mind me talking about
it but I was fascinated by the reaction
of people because they liked us as a
couple they liked us we love each other
again we are so near the best not
married couple ever we're happier than
most married people in fact we don't
even have lawyers but they're like why
are you divorcing you get along so well
I'm like you know well just cause me of
other things to do and so I think what
was interesting me not so much mangas
Megan is really wonderful and kind
and good was reaction people we bother
what I did bothered people I remember
watching reactions to people and a lot
of them was like you can't do that
like no you're great together we're like
I'm like how do you know like you know
name first of all how do you know like I
was talking about social media before
how do you know what's really going on
here and there was nothing awful going
on but it was like how do you know it
was and I then I realized oh it's about
them like it's about they are vaguely
unhappy and I've actually done something
about it you know what I mean like and I
said I I'm not happy and I said I'm not
unhappy I'm just not happy and I want to
be happy that's what I want and so it
really bothered a lot of people it was
really like and a lot I was like you've
invested all this time I said it's not
I'm investment a marriage is an
investment that you lose it if you stop
it you know what I mean we have
wonderful children we've got wonderful
times we still like each other we're not
mean to each other I was like it's not
an investment it just is done it's done
it's done and it we're not it's not done
in a cruel way it's not done anyway it
was really it's not perfect but it's cuz
it's leaving but it was fast the my
favorite response I had lots of a lot of
more they liked us as a couple because
we were you know famous lesbian couple
they love that like iconic and I get
that I get you know we were always on
the power lists and stuff which I hate
because they come in one lesbian couple
I have to find and now they don't have
one so I was like oh you're on a pair
I'm like I know I'm gonna power a couple
of I'm always on it we're always on it
like it or it like this it's like
sometimes Megan and I get lesbian Awards
I'm like wear it like they've run out so
forgive people awards too and so so we
were I was a friend of mine called me
and I told them and and so they were
like you never forgotten this they're
like how many how many percentage
unhappy were you alright how many
percentage I'm like what I didn't even
thought about in a numerical way and I
was like I don't know like she's like
50% 40% were you unhappy were you 60%
unhappy what's the percentage and I was
I was like I can't answer that I guess
60 70 I don't know like it was like
weird to try to quantify
and and there wasn't really that unhappy
it's just I wasn't where I wanted to be
and so I was I can't up the phone and
call another fan like she's getting
divorced like I knew it like she was
like oh that was good because she
started to reflect otherwise people get
disturbed by it because then they have
to compare it to their own experience
and what they're willing to tolerate and
that ice I wasn't apologetic about it
I wasn't we neither meg and I were
apologetic about it and we didn't feel
sorry for herself there was no drama
like there was no anger we were great to
the kids we talked to the kids really it
was bothersome it was fascinating to
watch and it's a first it was really it
was really interest cos people do
tolerate being just okay happy and I
don't want to be so on that mm-hmm no
this will be probably the last question
maybe the second last if you reflect
back on one of the toughest periods in
your life one of the darker periods if
you can place us mm-hmm when where that
is and what advice would you give that
person mmm gosh that's a good question I
haven't had that many dark periods um or
just yeah difficult um it's always been
a run relationships breaking up my
Breton breaking up broken up just as
many times as I broken up with people
and so I one thing I do do in relation
said he don't do and like I'm very good
about cutting things loose I'm not good
at that I'm not good about leaving the
relationship I always hope for better
like I can fix it so that's like a
that's a that's my problem like I try I
can I if I they only understood my
fantastic argument like and you can't
there's a really good Cheryl Strayed
quote about you can't make people love
you right you can't and so but I think
you of course you can and so I think
probably and now when I look back on it
it's like the same thing with school I
guess that didn't matter it didn't I
mean I'm sure it got me somewhere else
but when I I can't even recall that
emotion when I think back on that I you
know what one thing that really made me
sad and I shouldn't have done this maybe
I should have I probably should have but
I still wonder if I should have was I
went out with someone we had a we we
were very much in love and we broke up
anyway because we wanted different
things
you know you just have to know that with
your with anybody she didn't want kids
kids I wanted to live allowed life
during the quiet life it was just we
were too different but we really loved
each other just some people just spark
and stuff like that but really just not
for the long-term and it was devastating
to me because you you found someone you
connect with it's hard in life and I
couldn't be around her you know what I
mean it was a it was relatively mutual I
always kept trying to come up with
solutions like an idiot like Oh week if
we only like how do you how do you get
beyond I don't want kids right you don't
you know but I kept saying but if only
like and then I would have had to give
up kids which I would never have wanted
to do and so I was I kept trying to
figure it trying to figure it and figure
it and sometimes you just said drop
something you just say it's not fit it's
not fixable and so I didn't speak to
this person at all I just couldn't I
didn't want to be friends I had lots of
friends and it wasn't we weren't friends
you know what I mean and so who is
really interesting is I didn't contact
her for years and years and years I had
kids after it's like time passed and I
remembered that I might know I didn't
want a doctor I just didn't I knew that
I didn't I know I don't think she wanted
to talk to me and um and then I just let
time go and I wasn't mad anymore and I
didn't call her and I I wrote an email I
was thinking about I was a bunch of
friends and I wrote an email to her I
started to write an email and said we
should talk finally like I really like
and we really loved each other and we
loved each other and so I would like to
see you I love just catch up on your
life and I wrote the email I started it
and because I was with some friends that
reminded me of her and so I and I wonder
meet my kids and I was like oh it's time
time it's time and um and I didn't
finish it and I was getting on a point
it was like days later I was getting on
a plane and I get a coffee that Walt
Mossberg at the time and she had drowned
I think about God the day it was like
shocking like it was you know in her
basement it was this weird she did books
on tape for a living and so she had was
going down to collect some of her
recording equipment she's a wonderful
beautiful actress and beautiful reader
and she'd gotten caught it was a
terrible - I'm not gonna go into it in
detail but she drowned in her own house
I was like into a flood and it was just
like so [ __ ] random it was weird and
random and it's kind of like Oh Mike it
wasn't like a car accident or something
like cancer it was just like random as
[ __ ] like God just said you're gonna die
it was like I was just I literally had
an email sitting there waiting to send
and I didn't and I think I felt sick to
my I felt sicker than I've ever felt
that I didn't send it not that I would
have seen her necessarily but I kept and
I'm you know as you know I'm into time
travel and change of time I love that
Ray Bradbury story the one where he goes
back and steps on the butterfly and
suddenly we have knots he's kind of
thing you know in the future ooh and so
I was like what if I had written and
gone this here could I have stopped like
because I'm such an egomaniac but I
still was thinking of all that like why
didn't I do that like why did I so I'm
super interested in past not-taken like
if you don't turn this left okay today
if I go out here and I take it right
instead of a left what happens like I'm
very interested in that kind of stuff
that's another surprising thing I'm
super interested in that concept like
that movie with Gwyneth Paltrow was not
a great movie go doors subway doors or
something like that it she takes two
different moves and it changes
everything and they they show you both
of them and so so anyway so I didn't I
felt not because I didn't write her but
I remember thinking I should have done
that like I felt terrible for a long
time I still feel terrible at the same
time it was the right thing not to come
you know what I mean like so I felt it
was just a weird thing about it very and
I felt I was surprisingly upset by it
like why didn't I do what was what was
and I thought about it a lot why I
didn't and whether it was there I come
to collusion now that it was the right
thing not to be in touch but I part of
me wishes I had sent that email and gone
up to visit and said hello cuz you just
didn't know like same thing with my dad
you just didn't know what was gonna
happen
in world were so much as hard to predict
or impossible to predict and with so
much cynicism out there how do you
remain hopeful or optimistic well I'm up
you know I have my little I have all
these little rules and and mod that
rules I have these rules that I have um
I have I think there's there's
optimistic pessimists which I think I am
there's pessimistic optimists which I'm
not there's optimistic opposites Megan
for example and then there's pessimistic
pessimists and so I don't think I'm
hopeful at all what is an optimistic
pessimist um the world will be blowing
up at some point and none of it matters
like it does it's meaningless it's like
you know I'm not
so that's harder I wish I was religious
I think all of us do a little bit like
although religion has brought more pain
and suffering to this planet than almost
anything like right so I mean organized
religion and so I think that you I
really do believe the Sun is gonna blow
up and it's all gonna melt and worrying
about recycling or the elephants or a
Donald Trump isn't gonna matter one big
one bit some day just one day where does
the optimism fit in the usual domestic
you should live every day like that like
I'm in the Steve Jobs school that that
speech really impacted my listen to
that's Benji Stanford I have the inline
calendar to watch every Sunday every
it's Sunday every week Wow it's true
that is the most beautiful piece of
writing there's two beautiful I love
that I love that speech and the way he
delivered it it was very hard that's why
I like Steve Jobs I don't care if it's
fake it was a fan [ __ ] fantastic it's
not fake it wasn't fake he knows you
know and the thing is he created some of
the most amazing things in the years he
was dying not the other years the years
he was dying is when the great stuff
happens so his being cognitive that was
really important and the other one
people would be surprised to know but
I'm very patriotic and very us stuff get
every time a flag comes out I'm like you
SMA even though it's a lot of it's a lie
a lot of its we've done horrible things
in the name of our flag and I love the
Gettysburg Address I go see I go to
Lincoln Memorial all the time when I'm
in DC and I go read it again and again
and it's one of my favorite it's most
beautiful it's it's 800 words I actually
in my bag right now I have a copy of it
and the Gettysburg Address yes and how
many all the rewrites of it because I
love it it's just it's so hard felt
about how people aren't going to
remember of course every we remembered
it but what the sacrifices these people
made any kind of military cemetery I go
crazy and I'm like there's one up in San
Francisco that's amazing that has an
amazing quote from Auden I think maybe
not WH Auden
may it might be on I don't think it is
actually it's up above the Presidio
there's there's a little area there with
these amazing quotes about young men
dying it's okay so I find sacrifice
really profoundly moving you know the
stuff like that and so that one was
there's a line in Gettysburg Address
it's really
see look I carry the 14th amendment I
carry the 14th amendment and that could
equal rights under the logs of gay
things so when anyone argues me have a
gay rights I'm like Hello it's in the
Constitution equal rights under the law
but this is all about the history of it
and newspaper accounts I just found this
but there's four different copies
where's the original copy I like the
whole thing it's such a short time it's
like 800 words or something it's like
the most beautiful where is it mm-hmm
take you down I'm not about yeah I made
my sons memorize about Gettysburg
Address yeah it's the subtle thing but
I'm not that the world will note and
I'll remember but we said when he goes
Living Dead have struggling consecrated
it far above the poor power to add or
detract the world oh no don't remember
people remember that part this is a line
I love I love the whole thing it is for
us the living rather to be dedicated
here to the unfinished work which they
who fought here of thus far have thus
far so nobly advanced it is rather for
us to be here dedicated to the great
task remaining before us that from these
honored dead we take increased devotion
that the cause for which they gave their
last full my love the last full measure
of devotion its death right that we here
highly resolve that these dead shall not
have died in vain that the nation under
God have a new birth of freedom the
government of the people the last part I
know God the famous prophet it's this
last level of devotion and that honoring
that I it's for some reason this just
moves me this piece of writing because
it's really and then you know that he's
gonna die
this guy's gonna you know I mean like
what a narrative yeah you know you know
what's gonna happen to him and and and
that he was able to pull this out and
talk about something well beyond himself
I thought was just given all this
carnage was really quite beautiful this
is my favorite thing Carol I think
that's a great place to to put a button
and everybody should get a copy they
should it's a great speech and you can
memorize it you can memorize yeah did
you ever see the Ken Burns documentary
about this I haven't he gets kids to
memorize this passage it's a great it's
a great I don't love everything came
burns
but because they can take forever and
the quantity twonk KITT Confederacy
music gets to me after a while but the
he did a thing about autistic
statistical people with learning
disabilities learning to memorize this
and I vote and it was great it was so
moving it was beautiful and it was great
because they got it well Cara this has
been so much fun
yeah you're really appreciating the time
thank you where can people find
everything more about say hello on the
Internet yes at Kara Swisher if you
don't like insults of Trump please don't
tune in me and the Trumpkin czar yelling
at each other pretty much 24/7 at this
point I enjoy they don't get that I'm
enjoying tweaking them in there they
like think that called them sore winners
they go crazy get [ __ ] sore winners
Lee and they think I'm one of these
liberals like when let me just liberals
just really have to like stop like and
start to really tweak like you know they
make they get all offended by things I'm
never offended by things he says I'm
like what a [ __ ] douche like you know
getting like all I boom can you believe
it like they're they're always dude
that's that's how I operate with you
know writing that can you believe this
person do this I'm like I can believe it
yes people have done horrible things to
each other
if you're student of history you should
believe it like kind of thing and so I
like to get into it with from people
because they bite every time they're so
stupid a lot of them are but they just
bite every like it's so easy it's like
it's enjoyable and easy and there's your
Swisher Kara Swisher I think you can
write me at Kara a tree code note and
recoat notice our site I write week on
Tom's and then the podcast recode decode
which I that's most enjoyable thing I've
been doing lately as you know and you do
a great are you having a good time with
I love it podcasts are great that's how
much fun they're fun yeah it's really
big on absolutely we had James Corden on
recently wouldn't leave you have to go
and he's like I'm having a good time I
think I can't like use I'm like cuz you
could interview by dumb Hollywood
Reporter's all the time and so what soon
are you wearing well I will let you get
back to your day this has been great and
for everybody listening for links to the
Gettysburg Address and documentaries
everything that we talked about in the
show as well as how you can reach Kara
you can tune in to these show notes the
be found with the show notes for every
other episode of 4-hour workweek com
forward slash podcast and until next
time thank you for listening hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday the event provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
podcast is brought to you by me undies
does this year's Valentine's Day have
you stumped are you a big dumb animal
well skip the cliches and give a gift
that looks great feels amazing and makes
everybody happy me undies me and ease
knows that you're special someone
deserves a special fabric which is why
they're underwear it's made exclusively
out of micro modown fabric three times
softer than cotton I can feel it on my
loins right this very moment because
I've spent the last six months at least
wearing underwear from these guys 24/7
and they are the most comfortable and
colorful underwear you can add your own
character to your own underwear if you
don't love your first pair of munities
they say they will hook you up with a
free pair a new pair aurélie fun but are
you really an [ __ ] the returns
accused underwear if you are please stop
listening to my podcast that's
disgusting they offer free shipping in
for a limited time listeners of this
podcast get 20% off of their first order
just go to my undies com forward slash
Tim that's
nice calm forward-slash Tim this episode
is brought to you by athletic greens
I've used that fetid greens for many
many years and I'm asked all the time if
you could use only one supplement what
would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is my all-in-one nutritional
insurance at least that's how I think
about it it is much more than greens
it's a complete whole food supplement
with 75 or so ingredients packed into
one tablespoon per day so when I travel
for instance of course I would like to
follow all of my regimens all of my
pills all of my supplements all of my
food to the tea but sometimes
circumstances intervene and you're too
busy or things are too hectic this helps
me to mitigate the likelihood of getting
sick and to perform optimally so if I go
to say South America for an AcroYoga
intensive which I did in Colombia at one
point I was running around like a
chicken with its head cut off and I took
this every morning and it is extremely
extremely helpful and I usually travel
with travel packets among other things
so you should try it out is the short
version of this as listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show you can receive $100 worth
of travel packs for free when you order
that's 20 free additional individual
travel pouches when you order simply go
to athletic greens dot-com forward slash
Tim to check it out so take a look at
let it greens calm forward-slash Tim
you